اهلا بكم الى موجز لاهم الانباء تجددت
الاشتباكات صباح اليوم في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع وافاد مراسل الجزيره بسماع اصوات
الاشتباكات في مناطق بالعاصمه
اكد طرفان في السودان مشاركته ما في
محادثات تعقد في مدينه جده السعوديه هي
الاولى مدن اندلاع الازمه وقد رحبت الرياض
واشنطن بتلك المحادثات الاوليه واعربت عن
الامل في ان تؤدي الى انهاء للنزاع وقال
المتحدث باسم الجيش السوداني العميد نبيل
عبد الله للجزيره ان التفاوض يبحث اليات
تمديد الهدنه ولا يشمل اي اتفاق نهائي
لوقف اطلاق النار او قضايا سياسيه
وجه رئيس شركه فاجنر الروسيه
طالبا رسميا لوزير الدفاع الروسي لاصدار
امر عسكري بتسليم المناطق التي تخضع
لسيطره قواته في بخموت للقوات الشيشانيه
وكان بريكوجين قد اكد استمرار تقدم قواته
في مدينه بخموت رغم نقص الذخيره
وفي التطور عسكري لافت اعلن قائد القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه الفريق نيكولاي اوليشوك
اسقاط صاروخ روسيا من طراز كنجال فرد صوتي
في سماء كييف خلاله هجوم ليلي تعرضت له
الخميس الماضي ووصف اوليشوك اسقاط الصاروخ
لاول مره بالحدث التاريخي
اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانيه حاله التاهب في
جنوب بعد اسقاط مسيرات وسط انفجارات في
ميكو لايف
من جانب اخر اكد المدير العام لوكاله
الطاقه الذريه رافاييل جروسي البدء باجلاء
السكان من مدينه
النوويه وعبرغروسيا عن قلقه من تزايد
الاعمال العسكريه في منطقه المحطه التي
تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
هدمت جرافات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي صباح
اليوم الاحد مدرسه تحدي خمسه الاساسيه
بمنطقه جيب الديب في بيت تعمر شرق بيت لحم
بالضفه الغربيه المحتله ودارت مواجهات بين
قوات الاحتلال وفلسطينيين في محيط المدرسه
ما ادى الى اصابه عشرات من سكان البلده
بحالات اختناق
شيع امس سكان مخيم نور شمس في مدينه
طولكرم بالضفه الغربيه شابين فلسطينيين
قتلتهما قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وقد نعت
حركه حماس الشاهدين واكدت انتمائه مالك
كتائب القسام اكدت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
ان الشابين الشاهدين هما حمزه خريوش وسامر
الشافعي
وقد اعدت فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه الى
تصعيد المقاومه والاشتباك مع قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في جميع مدن الضفه
الغربيه دفاعا عن المسجد الاقصى والاسرى
في سجون الاحتلال
قالت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه ان التصعيد
الحاصله في انتهاكات وجرائم الاحتلال
سياسه اسرائيليه رسميه تعتمدها حكومه
اليمينيه المتطرفه على حد وصفها واكدت
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه ان الائتلاف الحاكم
ينسف بطريقه ممنهجه اي جهود اقليميه
ودوليه لاستعاده الافق السياسيه ورات ان
المطلوبه فرض عقوبات دوليه رادعه على دوله
الاحتلال لاجبارها على الانصياع لاراده
السلام الدوليه
نقلت وكاله رويتس عن الشرطه الامريكيه في
تكساس ان ثمانيه اشخاص قتلوا وان عددا اخر
اصيب في اطلاق نار امام مركز تجاري في
مدينه دالاس بولايه تكساس بالولايات
المتحده وقد لقي منفذ الهجوم مصرعه وفق ما
ذكرته وسائل اعلام محليه
توج الملك تشارلز الثالث وقرينته الملكه
كاملا على عرش المملكه المتحده في احتفال
هو الاضخم اقيم في كاتدرائيه ويستمنس في
لندن وحضر الاحتفال عدد كبير من زعماء
العالم وتوافدت جماهير غفيره الى لندن
لمشاهده الاحتفال وسط اجراءات امنيه مشدده
شارك فيها الالاف من رجال الامن
ختم الموجز شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]